everybody thinks
mass extinctions are a bad thing and for
some yeah
they were literally the worst but they
also show how nature can bounce back
in fact while extinctions are like a
large scale delete button
they're also a way to trigger some new
amazing life
there's been a lot of speculation about
the evolutionary role of mass
extinctions
and i think mass extinctions have been
really important i think they play
a really major role in opening up
ecological opportunities
for lineages to diversify and knocking
back lineages that have been dominant
for long periods of time
the really big mass extinctions are the
ones that
show up very dramatically in the fossil
record and those are fondly called
big five
the big five mass extinction are
scattered through the history of life
over the last
550 million years
and what caused them were things like
massive volcanic eruptions
climate changes and even apocalyptic
asteroids
the big five accounted for 50 and by
some estimates
up to 90 loss of all the species i think
these mass extinctions are important
evolutionary agents
that help shake the system loose
and because they open up large amounts
of ecological space
they probably do allow for
greater evolutionary inventiveness than
might have been
potentially possible in a situation of a
really crowded world
mass extinctions basically cleared the
decks and made room for new life
but it didn't happen overnight we are
talking tens of millions of years before
we saw life
start to make a comeback but eventually
after this one happened
lots of new fish came to be and here
both plants and reptiles really
diversified
then the first mammals and dinosaurs
here then after this
tons more dinosaur species and after the
mass extinction that killed off the
dinosaurs
there was a new sheriff in town terror
birds
there's a whole lineage of large
carnivorous birds
that diversified after the dinosaurs
went extinct through the cenozoic hero
some were just two or three feet tall
some of them were six or seven feet tall
and so those would be pretty spectacular
running around the landscape
chasing down their mammalian prey
[Music]
i think luckily for us they're gone
so dead dinosaurs meant new life for
them
and eventually new life for us
okay but seriously
how did anything survive one of the
rules that we find looking at every
single mass extinction and many other
extinction events besides
is that species that are widespread
geographically
preferentially survive the mass
extinction species that are spatially
restricted just in one little area
those preferentially go extinct what it
says to me
is that what really mattered was having
your evolutionary eggs
in many different geographical baskets
so what could this mean for humans and
future mass extinctions
we don't really know what sort of seal
activities are ahead
for the kinds of pressures that we're
bringing to bear on the ecosystem today
[Music]
humans will almost certainly survive in
some way
that's because humans have spread nearly
everywhere
[Music]
really more the question of the quality
of life of those humans
and who else will be left behind to
occupy the planet with us
and that's really an interesting
question there are plenty of species
that we rely on either directly or
indirectly that might fall
into the high extinction risk category
so understanding mass extinctions and
how species recovered
can help us a lot today there are some
fundamental
rules about how the world works under
stress
that we can in fact adopt and use to our
advantage to understand
what's taking place and something about
what's going to happen next
[Music]
you